Before we discuss categories three and
four, can we at least list the most
common errors from sections one and two?
The most grievious amongst the errors in
the first category that is errors
committed regarding the obligatory rules
and regulations of fasting is the most
common is that Muslims many a times they
don't do the nia for fasting intention
is very important without nia without
intention the fasting is not accepted so
making intention is obligatory and we'll
be discussing this inshallah in detail
inshallah tomorrow. The second error is
that many of times Muslims even after
the fudar aan has started yet they
continue eating and they think that the
end of su time is only at the end of the
fajar azan. In fact, the moment the
fudar aan starts, the moment the
beginning of dawn starts, the sore time
ends. So this is error which normally
nullifies or invalidates the fast. The
third error in the first category is
that many people they delay paying their
zakat
and many times they pay after the ydul
salah. If we pay the zakat after
then it is like normal charity it does
not come under the zakat. So these three
are the most grievous in the first
category. The common errors committed in
the second category that is errors that
are contradicting the sunnah of the
fasting is number one
many people they skip their sah.
Some people they have an early suhur
that is they have the suhur one or two
hours before the fud time. In fact sur
is a blessing every Muslim should have
it and the prophet said we should delay
the sur as much as possible. We should
have it till just before the fud time.
The third mistake committed by Muslims
in this category is that they delay
opening their fast. They delay thear and
our prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said that the people will be good as
long as they hasten in breaking thear.
That means immediately after sunset they
should break thear.
The fourth common error in this category
is that many Muslims they read
unauthentic dua
during iftar.
The most authentic dua as far asar is
concerned is
inshallah which means that
my thirst is quenched. The veins are
moistened
and
the aar is near.
Inshallah, God willing, the reward is
near, God willing. And some people when
they read this dua for breaking the
fast, they say it before breaking the
fast,
before they put their date in the mouth,
they say this and it is contrary to the
meaning. The meaning says that my thirst
has been quenched.
My thirst has been quenched and the
veins have been moistened. Your thirst
cannot be quenched before breaking the
fast. So normally it should be said
after you eat the after you have water
and you're satisfied maybe after some
minutes after you break the fast then
you can eat this dua
inshallah which means
my thirst have been quenched the veins
have been moistened
the reward is near inshallah God
willing.
The sixth
common error made by Muslims in this
category is that many Muslims they eat
excessively during and many of them even
eat throughout the night.
The seventh common error is that many of
them they are negligent as far as Taravi
is concerned because Taravi is not a
fur. They think it is no problem if a
Muslim misses taravi. Though taravi is
not a fur, it's a very important sunnah.
And a Muslim who misses taravi is
missing a great deal of reward.
And many Muslims who perform taravi,
they read taravi very fast, 10 miles per
hour. They try and finish it in a short
time and they defeat the purpose. In
fact, you should read with a moderate
pace so that people understand and they
grasp the message of Allah subhana wa
tala. The ninth common error is that
those who go forth in the mosque many of
them they socialize during as though
it's a time to meet people and friends
which is totally contrary to the sunnah.
The 10th common error is that many of
the Muslims think that the is on the
27th night of Ramadan
and they only worship Allah subhana wa
tala on this night. In fact, a beloved
prophet wasallam said
search for the in the odd nights of the
last 10 days, the last ashra, the 10
days. Therefore, kad can fall either on
the 21st night or 23rd or 25th or 27th
or 29th. So, this is one of the common
errors made by Muslims. The 11th common
error is that they spend their time
during Ramadan in unproductive work
rather than spending in zikar and
worshiping Allah subhanaa tala. They
should spend their time rather for
offering besides the compulsory salah,
the naful, the voluntary salah, the
sunnah salah. The 12th error made by the
Muslims is that they should do dua.
The 13th is they should ask for
forgiveness. This is month of
forgiveness.
14th is they should read the Quran as
much as possible
to get the blessings of Allah subhana wa
t'ala. The 15th is that they fast and
they keep themselves hungry but
basically they're not mentally prepared
for that fast and it is as though
they're staying hungry but the main
purpose of fasting to acquire tawa is
not obtained. This was in brief
regarding the second gaggate.